good evening
my name is Dennis Turner from the
Religious Studies department and
Divinity School Dean axe which you can't
and the apologizing for it can't be here
asked me to do the introduction how many
did I was caused to reflect on the
difference in style between the way
bricks do it and the way it's done here
Terry you'll remember this it works like
this if we were in a British University
I would say there is absolutely no need
to introduce so famous a person's Terry
Eagleton and I'd sit down because
there's no need to do it
however stands are more elaborate here
and rhetorical and I thought about it
ought to say something and Terry you
will remember 38 years ago you and I
taught a summer school in a place called
Manhattanville College and there are two
things I remember from that no three one
was every day you got lost between your
office and the classroom and we had to
go in search for you
secondly we discovered a most excellent
television program called Sesame Street
and in fact I seem to remember you
rearranged your classes so it's been a
ballistic thirdly and this is my memory
I discovered the dialectic from you and
that I was caused to think about that by
last week's lectures number one last
Tuesday was to me a poverty marvelous re
narration simply of the Gospels number
two number one was with a view to
getting ditch Kings to upgrade the
standards of fair critique fairly clear
wasn't it from what Terry said that
there's a certain element of a straw man
being knocked down the second on
Thursday reminded us that actually the
history of the update of those Gospels
amounts to
a significant series of betrayals and
thirdly that there's something
significant about this this is not a
form of liberal even-handedness this has
something to do with the dialectic
because what was really important about
this was the better critique of
institutional Christianity was actually
to be found in the Gospels than in
Dawkins and Hitchens and then I think
was something which you also were saying
about capitalism it was something you
were also saying about America and
American influence and foreign policy
and I think this is highly significant
that actually the best form of critique
is the auto critique which emerges from
within the thing which is being
criticized that it seemed to me said a
great deal about as it were the light
handed Marxism which is coming through
particularly on Thursdays lectures what
are we going to get today I don't know I
hope Terry does but it's supposed to be
something in the territory of faith and
reason is that not like Terry over to
you
and the fourth thing about
Manhattanville College Denis was them
wasn't it the mass of the beautiful
thing you know it isn't it
these of course were the days the the
trendiest post attics in two days one
could imagine 1970 with 200 nuns who not
not assure you not penguin but signal
cigarette smoking high-heeled with
lipstick almost all of whom I shall now
have at least four children very very
nice husband and there was a rather
genial but crazed the chaplain if I
remember full of the effervescence of
the Spirit and of nothing to who did
various bizarre masses one of which I
think he was dressed entirely in
newspaper I think to communicate some
point about communication
then I but if the pH de resistance was
that was the so-called mass of the
beautiful thing where he asked us at the
end of the previous week's mass to bring
next week some beautiful thing adding of
course bring yourselves above all in his
pious phony earnest
bogus way and Dennis and I were late for
mass and we had to find a beautiful
thing in about two twenty seconds we
found two identical fir cones outside
the door
cones drops from the fir tree and at one
point we had solemnly to exchange we
were asked first of all to contemplate
our beautiful things Dennis I stared
long and blankly at our cones then we
were asked I think even to smell them
and but certainly at one point to become
them both tried to feel suitably small
crinkled dry and then we were asked to
exchange our beautiful thing with
another whereupon Dennis nice solemnly
exchanged
identical fur coat we will write a book
on this at some point before yes I am
indeed going to talk about this time
about faith and reason something that I
think theologians theologically minded
people share with political radicals and
also with people of a psychoanalytic
bent Freudians and the rest which is the
paradox that without reason we're sunk
were finished yet reason is not in the
end what is most fundamental about us
and keeping as it were both sides both
ends of that paradox keeping a closed
hand on both ends it's pretty difficult
Richard Dawkins in The God Delusion
claims at one point with grandiloquent
folly that religious faith dispenses
with reason altogether which wasn't even
true of the thick-headed clerics who
knocked me around at grammar school high
school even even they didn't claim that
they dispensed really religion dispense
with reason altogether without so the
paradox is without reason we perish but
recent doesn't go all the way down
paradox splendidly
magnificent explored I think in some of
the novels of Thomas Mann in the magic
mountaintop the fastest in particular
you can't let go of reason but reason
will itself dwindle to a kind of
impoverished and brittle rationalism of
a kind not very far I think from Dawkins
at least if it isn't it doesn't
recognize that it isn't all there is if
it doesn't pay its dues if it doesn't so
to speak acknowledge its loyalty to some
origins beyond itself without reason
then we perish but the paradox his
reason doesn't go all the way down even
Dawkins has been known to emerge from
his laboratory from time to time
and there are even those on charitable
commentators who have detected the
mildest whiff of obsessive irrationalism
in his zealous campaign for secular
rationality and another old paradox of
course push reason to a certain limit
and it capsizes into its opposite it cup
sizes into irrationalism Dawkins is anti
religious zeal makes the ground
Inquisitor look like a soggy liberal
indeed Dawkins seems to nurture a
positively Maoist kind of faith in faith
itself you know in the hopelessly
idealist conception for example he seems
to share that religious ideology is what
fundamentally drives radical Islam as
opposed to say material conditions or
some perceived political injustice which
seems to me what most radical Islamists
say is that motivation Dawkins sweeps
that grandly aside in his obsession with
religion and talks and Caesar sees
radical Islam itself as as it were
wholly motivated by religious ideas his
belief in the power of religion is every
bit as robust as the Pope's to claim
that without reason we're sunk yet in
the end reason isn't where it's at
and yet not to cave in to one of the
many varieties of irrationalism is as
hard for the political radical to
sustain that fine tension as it is I
think for the theologian or indeed for
the Freudian to respect the ego Freud of
course a great rationalist and the great
enlightenment radical enlightenment
tradition yet somebody of course who
recognized that reason was not at the
master of its own house who showed us
magnificently however why that was so
it's only if reason can draw upon
resources more tenacious and less
fragile than itself
that it's capable of prevailing can't
prevail by itself that's not as a say
that something else would prevail rather
than for reason itself to prevail it
must constantly tapped Energy's
resources capacities which in the end
run deeper than reason itself and that I
think is a truth which liberal
rationalism of a ditch khun's
variety rather disastrously overlooks
and that brings us then to the question
of faith and reason which is not as
indeed as I've tried as I've tried to
intimate here is not just a theological
question what I've said there obviously
has a reach as a purview beyond theology
itself but I'll talk a little bit now
about faith and reason and a theological
sense there is probably I suppose no
greater evidence of Dickens's
theological illiteracy now the fact that
he appears to subscribe to what I
previously in these lectures called the
yetee view of faith I mean by this of
course the view that God is a sort of
object which like the Yeti or ley lines
or the Loch Ness monster or the tooth
fairy or unidentified flying objects the
evidence so far in is radically
ambiguous not to say you know deeply
dubious and because we can't thus
demonstrate God's existence in the
reasonably straightforward way that we
can demonstrate the existence of
necrophilia or Michael Jackson
then we have to put up with somebody
something less than certainty known as
faith well that's the yeti view of the
faith yes she had shared as it were by
most atheists most agnostics and I'm
afraid most Christians too I scarcely of
course need to point out to this
distinguished and utterly privileged and
special company he said groveling ly I
scarcely Nietzsche's point out to you
what our what a travesty of Christian
faith at least this is so that on the
most elementary questions of the
theology on which he chooses to
pronounce with such pretentiously self
regarding Authority Dickens is
hopelessly at sea even as it were at
square one
here yes for one thing of course God
differs from the you know from
unidentified flying objects or the Yeti
or the tooth fairy in not being even a
positive a possible object of cognition
it's just that we don't not just that
don't happen to be able to see him it is
as it were that are not seeing him is
inherent to God himself which is
presumably not true of the Yeti if he
exists or or the tooth fairy
I'm sorry if anybody here believed in
the tooth fairy but I don't hasten to
add of course it does exist for another
thing faith of course is traditionally
regarded as a question of certainty you
know even more scandalously
for the Dickens lives of this world not
as a question of probability or
speculation or guesswork but actually as
a question of certainty which is not to
say that it's not also traditionally
regarded as being inferior to knowledge
which it is but only fully paid-up
rationalists think that nothing is
certain but knowledge faith as the
author of the the sort of the Hebrews
writes is the assurance of things hoped
for the conviction
of things unseen whatever else may
divide science theology or religion it's
from a theological view certainly not
the question of certainty don't think
Dickens understands that in the least a
certainty in question to be sure it's
not the same kind of certainty of that
of a well entrenched scientific
observation like you know it's just
turned red you know the mouse is clearly
drunk and we are now calling off the
experiment experimenter is clearly
trunks it's not a statement of that kind
of certainty to be sure but then neither
are statements like I love you which as
Jonathan color has pointed out is is
always a quotation but that's quoted the
piece of language I love you of course
however Bern England sincerely said
staring into their eyes at the time is
of course you know the dreariest of
quotations totally intertextual it's not
it's statements statements certain
statements like I love you or you know
liberal democracy is a lot better than
slavery
you know the overweening emma Woodhouse
finally gets comeuppance yes these are
not statements of a scientific term but
they are pretty certain for most of us
even so this isn't to claim as as as
Dawkins seems to imagine in the case of
religion but what Mars really saying
there is that religious propositions
don't don't need evidence at all Dawkins
makes the disastrous error I think of
thinking but to say that they're not
scientific is therefore to say that
there
but they have no concern with the
evidential whatsoever
if jesus' body is mingled with the dust
of Palestine then Christian faith is in
vain
it's rather to suggest that though for
example I must be prepared to explain a
tedious length what it is about you that
I find so lovable to give all kinds of
reasons for that to argue the case no
adducing bodies of evidence
demonstrating this or that arguing over
the existence or non-existence of this
particular quality in you
I'm also forced to recognize that
someone else might see all this as well
in you and not love you at all the
evidence itself will not decide the
issue at some point along the line a
particular way of seeing the evidence
one perhaps implicit from the outset
comes into play one which involves a
particular kind of personal engagement
with it and none of that is reducible to
the evidence itself in the sense of
being in a lot to be motivated by a bear
account of the situation I might note by
the way the difference between that
image of faith and the dubious notion
that reason can take us so far
after which some kind of existential
leap in the dark proves to be essential
I don't think that's the right model you
can know all you need to know as let's
say a journalist about the sonnets to
Orpheus but this is no guarantee that
they won't believe you code the evidence
itself as it were will not move you
necessarily to a certain kind of
engagement with the object and none of
that sure they should strike a scientist
scientists like Dawkins as unfamiliar
because I take it that scientists are in
an important sense not only believers
but actually
some sense east additions elegance in
science will get you a very very long
way the universe is a matter of style
the truth of the universe is a matter of
style all scientists not closet Oscar
Wilde Ian's and as Ron Williams
remarks all communication involves faith
or communication involves faith of some
kind
and since reason is itself of course a
collaborative and biological and
communicative affair and I think that
the positivists often goes sadly wrong
by not seeing that by seeing it as a
much more as it were monastic affair
since reason is all the matter in
dissociative Li a matter of dialogue and
communication that collaboration then
then if all communication involves faith
this must apply to reason and to reason
is a dialogue and dialogues always
evolve a kind of faith nor as we know
another familiar mistake made by the
ditch kids's of this world nor is faith
in the first place a matter of
subscribing to the proposition that a
Supreme Being exists for one thing God
doesn't exist in as an entity in the
world atheists and believers are agreed
on this and for another thing as I've
argued before in these lectures faith is
in the first place performative rather
than propositional which is not to argue
that it's not coachable in terms of
opposition's or as we traditionally say
doctrines just that it's not in the
first place a matter of descriptions of
reality it resembles an utterance like I
have faith in you more than it does a
statement like no I believe in goblins
Abraham has faith but it's surely
doubtful that you could even have
conceived of God not existing
but he had faith even so the militant
left-wing atheist Alain Badiou
probably the greatest living French
philosopher author of absolutely
splendid
Wilkinson Paul understands this far
better than does his anglo-saxon liberal
rationalist counterparts bad.you
understands totally as Marxist an F or X
Marxist X Maoist atheist militant
atheist but faith articulates a loving
commitment before it counts as a
description of the way things are though
that it involves a description of the
way things are is as clear as the fact
that moral imperatives do served us so
must do so as well
propositions that can be true or false
have their roots in kinds of experience
which can't be treated quite that way
and would not be authentic if they
didn't have theirs one thinks perhaps of
the nature of propositions in literature
or in fiction fiction contains all sorts
of propositions doesn't it you know that
Paris is in France or whatever or snow
is white it would simply be under those
propositions that can be falsified or
verified it certainly is simply a fact
that part of what we need my fiction is
that those propositions are not there
for their own sake as descriptions of
the world they're there as it were of
supports to a kind of rhetorical or
performative attitude the world as
stands to the world which is what
actually matters
that's why certain propositions in
fiction can be actually obviously false
and doesn't really make any difference
yet as I say this is not to say of
course that the truth or falsehood looks
like propositions pails into nothing
besides the depth of the experience from
which they spring a believer after all
is someone in love observes Kierkegaard
in the sickness unto death a statement
of course by no means applies only to
religious believers in santa customs
view one can't arrive at the truth
except through a kind of love for some
tanks own reason itself is rooted in God
so that faith must be reasons foundation
this is what he means by all part of
what he means I suppose by his
celebrated statement I believe in order
to understand a proposition which in a
different sense many kinds of believers
such as socialists or feminists could
also make all reasoning as we know is
conducted within the ambit of some kind
of faith however inarticulate it may be
for Thomas Aquinas love precedes truth
and is the precondition of it we seek
truth because fatah --mess because our
material bodies manifest are built-in in
a radical desire for it a desire which
for Aquinas is the inscription within us
of divine love without love no truth
faithful Christian tradition is actually
what makes truth possible which is true
in an everyday sense as well I think
that faith is what makes truth possible
there's a belief relationship between
that and Lenin's statement that theory
would never be complete what you would
never arrive at a complete formulation
of theory Lenin once remarked without
the development of a mass political
movement letters say only on the basis
of a certain practical kind of
commitment and engagement with reality
politically speaking can theory itself a
correct attempt to describe reality
come to fruition it's because perhaps
we've come to Moloch to model knowledge
on things rather than on persons that we
fail to see this implication of
knowledge and faith that for example
only by having faith and trust in
somebody can we really come to disclose
ourself ourselves fully to them and
therefore be known that's one way
perhaps among a manifold number of ways
in which truth and faith go together we
have to have a certain faith in trust in
somebody else to be able to manifest
ourselves to him or her in a full kind
of way this is one of several sensitives
presumably in which knowledge and virtue
go together because that self
manifestation involves a certain kind of
risk it involves a certain amount of
courage to do that as the Duke rebukes
the slanderous Lucio in Shakespeare's
measure for measure love talks with
better knowledge and knowledge with
dearer love in the end only love of
which faith as Kida God sees is one form
the somebody believer is someone in love
as he says only in the end only love can
achieve the well nigh impossible goal of
seeing the situation as it actually is
Shawn of both the deceptive enchantments
of romance and the disheveled fantasies
of eros love endures to other inferior
senses realism of course demands all
kinds of virtues I mean simple realism
in the sense of simply trying to get to
see the situation as it actually is
demands all sorts of virtues not some
sort of clinical matter it demands an
openness to being wrong a certain
humility as a selflessness a certain
proper eight preparedness for
collaboration certain generosity of
spirit a lot of hard labor
conscientious judgment and so on and for
Aquinas all virtues or such virtues have
their roots in love so love is not
irrelevant to the very practical issue
as it were of simply trying to see the
situation as it is which is of course
the basis of all moral and political
achievement bases of all moral and
political achievement is the humble and
essential matter of trying to see things
as they are
a very very basic level enterprise which
we have a reason to believe may well be
impossible love is the ultimate form of
cold-eyed soberly disenchanted realism
which is why it is the twin of truth the
true life and truth also have in common
the fact that they are both usually
unpleasant
I mean radicals are people who hold the
truth is usually a lot less powerful
than they want us to believe a necessary
dash of paranoia comes in there I think
wrong with a bit of paranoia between
friends
just as people who don't believe in
spirits ease fantasies to the core you
know all of these fantasies who don't
believe in conspiracies very strangely
and and we've seen already in our
discussion of the New Testament that
there's nothing lovely about love you
know we've seen just where love is
likely to land you Pascal comments that
the Saints he says maintain that we must
love things before we know them
presumably because only through a
passionate engagement with them can we
come to know them at all truly
dispassionate mrs. death of knowledge in
that sense below not every sense of the
word that's whatever the liberal may
think I suppose there are some nowadays
who would regard faith in socialism as
even more eccentric than a belief in the
assumption of the Blessed Virgin into
heaven why then to some of us still
cling to this political faith in the
teeth of what many people would regard
as reason and solid evidence not only I
think as I said before that socialism
seems to be such an extraordinarily good
idea but it's proved exceedingly hard to
discredit and this despite its own very
best efforts to do so
it's also I think not only that it's
because one can't accept that for
example the world that we see groaning
in agony around us is all there is or or
there could be even though we accept
that empirically speaking this might
indeed be the case this is perfectly
possible it's also because one gazes
with wandering bemusement upon those
hard-headed types for whom all of this
all we see around us perhaps given a
reformist week or two is as good as it
gets
and finds that utterly bewildering
because to back down from this vision
would be to betray what one feels are
the most precious powers and capacities
of human beings because however hard one
tries one simply can't shake off the
perhaps primitive or infantile
conviction that this is not how it is
supposed to be however much we're aware
that the seeing of the world in the
light of Judgment Day as felt opinion
might put it is folly the wise and a
stumbling block to stockbrokers because
there's something in this vision which
calls to the very depths of our being
and evokes a passionate assent there
because not to feel this would be not to
be what sells would be not to be oneself
because one is too much in love with
this vision of humankind to back down
walk away settle for half more take no
for an answer
all of which of course as we can see
from the from the death of a salesman
from Willy Loman who is unable to back
down say no take no for an answer
settle for half or walk away will lead
directly to a certain kind of tragedy to
a certain kind of tragic and pass on
death now none of that seems to me to
run counter to reason as it would say if
the world was already a nuclear
wasteland from which nothing could be
southern engine
need those kinds of commitments could be
said to be unreasonable it's just that
it's a different kind of thing from a
scientific observation or an everyday
piece of cognition as indeed ditch kins
is belief in the value of individual
freedom is different from a scientific
observation nichkhun's can't ground his
beliefs in freedom and freedom of
inquiry and the need for rational debate
he can't ground those scientifically and
there's absolutely no reason in my view
why he should be required to do so these
then are perhaps some of the ways in
which reason doesn't go all the way down
it's also the case isn't it that we need
a commitment to reason itself one which
is not perhaps reducible to reason we
need to be committed to reason we can
always ask ourselves for example why
discovering the truth should be thought
so desirable some people have thought it
wasn't Nietzsche didn't think it was
very desirable necessarily nor some of
the time perhaps did Henry Gibson or
Joseph Conrad I mean what rancor malice
resentment anxiety or urged to Dominion
Nietzsche might acquire lurks behind
this obdurate will to truth if we're to
defend reason we must be inspired by
more than reason to do so there are
legitimate legitimate disputes surely
over the nature and status of
rationality itself which are far from
evolving any kind of irrational ism to
what extent for example reason
encompasses the aesthetic imaginative
sensuous intuitive and effective in what
sense it might be as I say a dialogical
affair what counts as a rational
foundation whether reason inherently
implicates the values of freedom
autonomy and self-determination whether
it's substantive or procedural apathetic
or evidential instrumental
or autotelic to what extent it
represents in its totalizing and
apparently all explanatory nature a
recycled version of the very mythologies
that it seeks to oust and Horkheimer
would argue whether as I said before
it's been modeled primarily on our
knowledge of things or our knowledge of
persons what relations the rational ego
maintains with the super-ego and the
primary processes what we make of the
fact that even before we've started to
reason the world is in principle
intelligible to us in the first place
what if it wasn't could we imagine that
whether it's true that we reason as we
do primarily because of what we do
whether reason is to be associated with
common sense and moderation as it is
with the liberal rationalists or with
revolution as it was by John Stuart Mill
and the Jacobins whether reason only
takes flight at dusk whether it's to be
contrasted with our animality or seen as
an integral part of it and so on many
questions we could raise about the
status of nature of rationality in its
relation to other things for Aquinas to
revert to him once again and to quote
Dennis Turner rationality is the form of
our animality bottle eNOS is the stuff
of our intellectual being theology in
that sense is a species of materialism
we reason as we do because of the kind
of material creatures that we are we're
reasonable because we're animals not
despite being so if an angel could speak
you would not be able to understand what
he said it's hard to feel that such
considerations lie the forefront of the
mind of Richard Dawkins whose callow
rationalistic complacency is adjust the
thought that Jonathan Swift so
savaged so if a rationalist hasn't been
said who didn't believe in reason it's
equally hard to think that those
questions have been much brooded over
bike route by Christopher Hitchens in
Robert bolts play and man for all
seasons thomas moore advances a very
catholic defense of reason Mandy says
has been created by God to serve Him and
the wit and tangle and cunning of his
mind not simply in simplicity like the
flowers for example but in a very
cunning them deviousness of his
intellect that itself as a kind of
service of God when a new version of the
oath of allegiance to the king is
published more eagerly asks his daughter
Susanna what the wording is and his
daughter Susanna replies in rather
Protestant style Oh daddy what was the
word one of the words matter to which
more applies in his good old
materialistic papist achill way an oath
is made of words I may be able to take
it yet it's the same war you know a
stickler for the material the same or
who pressed by the exasperated Susanna
on why he will declare his loyalty to
the king berated by Susanna because she
says daddy it just isn't a reasonable
replies well in the end it isn't a
matter of reason in the end it's a
matter of love all reasoning is carried
on within some kind of faith including
the faith in reason itself for the
Philosopher's Feaster faith they're not
necessarily of the religious variety is
prior to and foundational of all
knowledge knowledge moves within the
assumptions as we know which are
embedded in our practical boundedness
with the world and which can never be
precisely formalized or thematized
as witnessed on remarks in uncertainty
it is what we do which lies at the
bottom of our language games
know-how precedes knowledge and never
ceases to underpin it this is not
consider to concur with the postmodern
pragmatists and relativists that reason
is therefore too much on the inside of
our way of life ever to operate as an
effective critique of it I mean that
argument might be thought to follow from
the idea that reason the roots of reason
run down to what we do run down to our
ways of doing things our ways of carving
up the world all right the postmodern
pragmatist or Atlas might say that means
that reason is absolutely bound up with
our culture is it well on the inside of
it and therefore the idea that reason
could ever you know put enough daylight
between itself and what we do to operate
as a critique of what we do is an entire
fantasy factory's would there have to be
standing at some Olympian or Archimedean
point in which which simply doesn't
exist in the first place well I don't
think that's right I think that's a
mistake this is the idea that the
criteria which determine what is to
count as reasonable must themselves be
derived from the very form of life that
they seek to put under critical scrutiny
yes the very criteria which counters
what is reasonable and therefore we do
seem to offer a kind of overview and
monitoring of our way of life actually
themselves according to this view are
drawn from our way of life and have no
basis in any other place I think what
that forgets among other things is that
it's part of the way in which the human
animal is actually bound up with the
world that it's able to distance itself
from not least by labor and language
that's not a kind of you know
because transcendence as though we can
really thought of our skins and leap out
of our world it's actually part of the
way we in the world has laboring
linguistic creatures communicative
creatures relational creatures that were
able to some degree again kind of fix
upon it in the way that it seems you
know squirrels and goldfish can't I
don't wish to be in at least you know
obviously patronizing or condescending
to squirrels or my best friends no I
just they don't look as though they're
engaging in ferocious and fundamental
critique you know and of course because
they're not they are marvelously safe
because they're so integrating with
environments because they're not cursed
and blessed with that awful double-edged
sword called language or developed
consciousness they're not capable you
know of bringing themselves over
reaching themselves bring themselves to
nothing as the linguistic animal is so
the doctor or implicit certainties or
taken for granted truths which
constitute the matrix of all our more
formal reasoning are as obvious in the
case of science as opposed as much as
anywhere else I mean this much at least
one might say the postmodern skeptics
have have going for them where it comes
to science though one should bear in
mind that humanists humanists have
always been prejudiced against
scientists it's just the over the years
they've shifted their grounds for this I
mean the scientists used to be you know
my day scientists used to be regarded as
unspeakable winks with dandruff on their
collar and leather patches on their
sports jackets elbows you know who
thought that Rambo was a cinematic
strong man rather than a French poet
they've now become for a later epoch the
authoritarian custodians of
absolute truth yes their petal is now
for the postmodern objection to science
of an obnoxious ideology known as
objectivity a notion which simply tarps
up
they are illogical prejudices
unacceptably disinterested guys
interestingly one thing that's happened
in our time is that the burden of the
critique of science the resistors the
science has shifted from a traditional
humanism to a kind of cultural ism
culturalism is now one of a long series
rather dishonorable series of critics of
science culturalism I mean that
intellectually violent attempt to
repress or eradicate nature altogether
in the name of culture one doesn't need
to subscribe of course this absurd
caricature to note that science like
every other human practice is indeed
shot through with prejudice and
partisanship and on thematize of all
assumptions unconscious biases beliefs
too close to the eyeball to be
objectified and so on if the Virgin Mary
were to put in an appearance this very
moment over the skies in New Haven
you know clutching the baby Jesus with
one hand nonchalantly distributing a
hundred-dollar notes with the other it
would be more than the reputation of
anybody laboring away in the Yale
elaborate ruse was worth even
fractionally to put their heads out of
the window there are still in other
words our good many telescopes at which
science is churlish really disinclined
to peer there are those topics which in
Foucauldian phrase are in the truth in
the truth at any given time and those
which happen not to be in the truth at a
particular time Marxism used to be in
the truth quite recently it isn't now
it's not so much that it's run out of
facts is that it's out of theater I
happen to know for example as a fact
that that the moon deeply affect affects
human behavior since I'm a mild kind of
lunatic I'm always aware
the moon is full even without looking
though I don't go quite as far as paying
or sprouting hair on my cheeks but I
doubt that any scientist who valued
their corporate grants would fall over
themselves to investigate this
remarkably well-researched well evidence
phenomenon rather like the literary
critic publishing of three-volume work
on goosey goosey gander though Dawkins
is The God Delusion
is astonishingly tightly astonishingly
laconic about the cock-ups
and catastrophes of science you know
Dawkins castigates the Inquisition but
not in Russia not the world that science
has actually helped to create most of
the show they are aware that like almost
any interesting human pursuit from
staging a play to running the economy
science is a lot more dicey precarious
anomalous and a serendipitous than its
publicity agents would prefer us to
think and that many of its practitioners
will go to quite extraordinary lengths
to preserve a trying to untrusted
hypothesis
none of that however is in my view to
discredit that loving passionate
selfless faithful exhausting profoundly
ethical labour known as trying to get it
right in political life
it's a Labour which can make the
difference between life and death it's
also one which for all its necessary
demythologizing could be said to have
religious rules Charles Taylor has
pointed out how the scientifically
detached or disinterested subject of
modernity has its historical origins or
some of them in pre-modern religious
asceticism with its contemptuous Mundi
in order to know the world is strange
irony give us at the same time rich
it in a similar way Heidegger regards
the Cartesian notion of certainty as a
hangover from a certainty of religious
faith even so yet the fact remains that
there are those for the sake of whose
flourishing and will who those who for
the sake of their flourishing and
well-being need to know more or less how
things stand with them what everybody
what everyone needs to know that but
there are those people
so placed in society that in order to
flourish and to have some well-being
they need to know rather insistently on
how things stand with them and there are
those rather more privileged Souls some
of them known as post modernist for whom
this represents simply an ideological
evolution
some people need knowledge to do
important things with it and others
don't so science is to that extent
surely about faith as well which is not
all it shares in common with theology
and rather as the church's can be said
to have largely betrayed their
historical mission so one might argue
has a great deal of science I myself was
twenty years a fellow of Wadham College
Oxford an institution which in the late
17th century was home to the Royal
Society one of whose founders John
Wilkins was the warden of Wadden and was
the brother-in-law of Oliver Cromwell
unlike most of the rest of Oxford the
college was on the progressive side of a
civil war and suffered rather badly for
it and Wadhams rather traditionally
dissident politics lasted as long into
the 20th century in the form of the kind
of Bloomsbury liberalism basically
reflected by its 20th century warden
Samaras aspera who was rash enough to
take me on as a young fellow largely I
think because he fancied me
Yunos based upon the attractions of a
rather elderly or bloomsbury person I
really don't like to think about that
too much I like to say I like to think
it was part of my merits that I've
collected the photo you know not just
new disreputable reasons of this kind
all of this had its roots in in this
revolutionary scientific lineage which
of course it's part of a history which
those today who are sometimes rather
glibly critical of science seem to
forget
rather conveniently a lineage which
prized fidelity to one's reasoning
experience and independent good sense
over loyalty to prelate and monarch the
fact that like religion much scientific
practice has betrayed its own
revolutionary impulses becoming the
obedient tool of corporate interests
shouldn't induce as I think to forget
this emancipatory history I had more
things to say but not all that much
actually I had I was going to go on to
talk about how far faith is something
that we choose or how find we far we
have far we find ourselves as it were we
find ourselves believing something what
that means and whether that's
deterministic or not but I've said
enough so I will